have you heard about all the drugs going
on I have now back in the day your
father and I would handle this and if he
was here now maybe we'd still endless
but he's not
that's on you Oh what I say is you gotta
handle this let's go my name is Matt
Wells I'm an actor and producer on the
independent feature film Crown and
Anchor which will be released
theatrically in the fall of 2018 Crown
and Anchor is an intense family drama
which examines the effects of childhood
trauma and it is scored entirely with
punk and hardcore music bands like
Gorilla Biscuits used to today dys
Johnny Thunders x-ray specs just to name
a few I made the movie in my hometown of
st. John's Newfoundland which is where I
am right now
hiding from the rain under the trees
made the movie with my best friend
Michael row and I met him when I was in
a band wearing a band together and
that's how my journey started into
filmmaking it started with music we
started to have some success on music
television in Canada we were touring
with bands like Slayer and fishbone and
do a eventually that journey led me into
music television so I all of a sudden
went from being a singer in this
independent bands to interviewing some
of the bands that I admired I became a
music and film journalist on music
television and through the years I got
to interview people like Lou Reed and no
doubt Greta Gerwig and Quentin Tarantino
but somewhere along that journey I
started to feel like I wanted to do
something different which was acting and
filmmaking and you can imagine what an
aspiring actor and filmmakers could
learn from interviewing people in that
world I did thousands of interviews and
it was always sort of percolating in my
in my brain to be quite honest with you
what I learned as a guy in an
independent band that's what gave me the
tools to be able to make a movie this
sort of DIY do-it-yourself
spirit of punk and hardcore music that's
that's what I lived that was my whole
life we were putting up our own posters
we were raising money to to make albums
and music videos running it like a small
business so we could go on tour and
sustain ourselves to continue doing
something that we loved and
that is exactly how we made this movie
and exactly how we're approaching the
rollout of distribution and when you
think about it
those world's independent film and
independent music that punk and hardcore
and do-it-yourself culture and spirit
they're very similar and that is exactly
the tools that we used to make Crown and
Anchor
our first day on set of Crown and Anchor
we shot 15 pages which was already
longer than any project our writer
director and Giroux had worked on in the
past we're sort of set to tone for the
next 15 days of filming this was Andrews
first feature and and we only had 15
days to make it happen but it created an
urgency on set which absolutely you can
see in the performances you can see in
the direction there's something about
being under the gun and knowing that you
really don't have it the option to make
a lot of mistakes or second-guess
yourself and that's really what we did
and the backstory of Crown & Anchor is
that we had private investors and we had
a strong script but it was long and
everybody told us it was too long at our
budget but we didn't want to have to cut
it because of budget because we knew if
we cut it in the script phase it was
going to cut the heart out of the film
and Andrew had a distinct vision for
this
movie about wanting to really focus on
character development which was gonna
mean a lot of long one-take no cutscenes
and and Michael and I we connected with
that vision we believed in it so we
wanted the ability to cut in the editing
room and not on the page so we knew we
had to assemble a team that was
amendable to that type of environment I
mean essentially we had to find people
who wanted to punk rock the out of
this thing and that's what we did we
found an amazing cast an amazing crew I
mean you know the good thing about
having a very strong script is that it
allowed us to attract very strong actors
who had been in the business for a long
time and without that sort of experience
never would we be able to make something
like this this was a no frills set there
were no dressing rooms no trailers it
was stripped down we had to have a team
that were checking their egos at the
door and were cool to work in that sort
of environment and just try to put all
the money on the screen which is what we
did and without this credible cast and
crew it never would have happened
so that really
it influenced and it was a big part of
the energy you see on screen but not
just the environment of production but
also the locations you know our creative
team are spread all over right now from
Toronto to California but our hometown
is st. John's Newfoundland where I am
right now and there's something really
special about this place and if you ever
if you have a project I highly recommend
you consider coming to make it here not
just because it has a growing and
thriving film community not just because
it has an amazing crew here really
talented actors and not just because
it's beautiful but because there's an
energy in this place it's it's an island
in the middle of North Atlantic Ocean we
are geographically isolated we are we
are socially and culturally unique
and it also informs our movie and if you
don't believe me how special it is here
just see if you can ask Jason Momoa I'm
sure you can just call him the guys here
all the time filming it's not a rare
occurrence to see him walking down the
street and going to grab a coffee
there's a very special place and there's
something about not to get in too much
of a history lesson about Newfoundland
but our ancestors through the years
having to live off the land and the
brutal climate that sort of helped
inform who we are and there is a dark
raw Beauty to Newfoundland and there is
a strong independence and you see that
in our film as much as you see
the influence from the words that were
on the script
so our biggest challenge is I mean like
most independent films it's budgetary
right we only had so much money and we
had to work around that
but honestly our biggest challenges on
Crown & Anchor came later as we went to
market and there were all self-inflicted
wounds like I said you know everybody
told us after reading the script that
they really thought it was strong but we
should not make a movie as first-time
filmmakers that was running at two hours
that maybe some of the scenes were too
intense
maybe we shouldn't score it with punk
and hardcore music because that might
alienate some audiences and that being
in such a beautiful part of the world
that we should focus on these exteriors
and show more of the landscape but we
did the opposite not because we are
stubborn or when we don't want to
collaborate it's because those choices
we felt were true to the characters and
shoot to the story and that's that's
what we wanted to do right so we made a
movie that runs just under two two hours
no a-list stars all punk and hardcore
music but these are the things that have
allowed us to get an international sales
agent these are the things that are
allowing us to have a North American
theatrical release as an independent
film and it's because it was authentic
to the story and I think to the
characters and that's what we
right as independent filmmakers what
we're trying to do is chase the
authentic stories and we knew all these
choices were only going to help the film
but again it's because we knew who our
audience was no one who your audiences
is so important and you know I go back
to this idea of do-it-yourself punk and
hardcore spirit from that music world
that we that inspired us so much that we
took into the independent filmmaking
process the same way we we use that when
we were in a band the same way we
thought about DIY when we are in
production the same way we're rolling
out distribution you know as independent
filmmakers we want to see our movie in
theaters right but it's not always
something that we have access to we
didn't want to go straight to DVD we
didn't want to go straight to VOD or
streaming so we've taken the same
do-it-yourself spirit and we partnered
with independent movie theaters across
North America to do our own theatrical
every independent film jury is going to
be different but this has been ours and
it's because we stuck to our vision it's
because we knew our audience and we're
willing to do the work because we
believed in what we are doing so I hope
you come out to see us when our film
hits your city you can check out our
website which is up on the screen here
and you know come out and talk to us
we're gonna do q and A's in some of the
cities afterwards with myself our writer
director and Giroux our lead actor
Michael Rowe who is also producer on
this with
we want to talk to you guys and hear to
hear your questions and know what you're
doing and tell you about filming and
Newfoundlands so that's it I hope you
get to check out Crown & Anchor it's
raining so I'm going to go inside thanks
for listening